hello there today we're going to look at
prompt breeder self-referential
self-improvement via prompt Evolution
this is a paper by Google Deep Mind
which is the new conglomerate between
Google brain and deep mind so it should
be fun the basic idea behind this paper
is that rather than writing your own
prompts for large language models for
them to do a particular task uh you have
a system that evolves prompts by itself
so you just kind of give it the
description of a task and it comes up
with its own prompts in order to have a
large language model solve the task
obviously the coming up with its own
prompts is also done by large language
models and is done via an evolutionary
algorithm The evolutionary algorithm if
you know evolutionary algorithms they
rely on sort of mutation and fitness
evaluation and in this particular paper
even the mutation part is
is done by large language models and so
that's what makes it self-referential
and self-improving is that it improves
its own method of generating improved
prompts we're going to look into this uh
it all gets a little bit complicated not
necessarily complex but complicated in
the sense of you know what are you
actually currently doing because every
single thing is handled by a large
language model but we'll dive into it at
the end of it it's not that
complicated and while the while kind of
the results seem promising uh if you dig
a little bit into them in my opinion
it's not it's not certainly not the end
of the problem like we haven't solved
the problem at all it just kind of
pushes the problem into a different
domain and if you look at the actual
results I kind of have a hard time
believing that you know this here is the
solution it's there's something going on
maybe but they do see considerable
improvements so we have to give them
that uh so the authors here say that
strategies like chain of fault prompting
can dramatically improve the reasoning
abilities of large language models so
rather than let's say you have a a
family of tasks like little math tasks
like Peter ate two apples and Peter ate
three apples how many apples did Peter
eat
uh you can just ask this to a language
model and it'll it'll tell you maybe
it's even correct but what people have
noticed is that you can dramatically
improve the final answer of a language
model if you say something like how
about you think step by step you you
tell that to the language model and what
you do is you kind of force it to break
down the problem into small chunks and
then perform these chunks individually
and explicitly and Via various
techniques of doing that you can get a
much better likelihood of The Final
Answer being correct than simply asking
your problem in the first place so these
various prompting techniques Chain of
Thought tree of thought step by step and
and so on uh all of this people have
come up with they had to sit down and
think and that's what they call here
these are handcrafted prompt strategies
and even though they work they're often
suboptimal prompt breeder which is this
paper uh they call is a general purpose
self-referential selfimprovement
mechanism that evolves and adapts
prompts for a given domain with the
point being that this is no longer a
manual process for us to sit down and
think okay uh how am I going to write
this please solve this math problem
think step by step each line write the
formula write the results on and so so
none of this anymore all of this this
coming up with the correct prompts is
now being done via this mechanism here
uh the mechanism as I said is evolution
evolutionary algorithm to evolve task
prompts and the clue of this paper is
the prompt reader is not just improving
task prompts but he is also improving
the mutation prompts that improve these
task prompts so that's the
self-referential
part uh they introduce again saying
prompting is Central prompting is
Central to the downstream performance of
foundation
models okay so if you if you buy into
this ridiculous term of foundation
models then in my opinion this here is
used slightly incorrectly because
prompting specifically refers to
language models and it actually doesn't
refer to Foundation models so none
nothing
models there are models that I can
prompt which can be classified as
Foundation models but also models that
would certainly not be classified as
Foundation models by even by the vague
original terminology around that term
and there are Foundation models that
cannot be prompted um at least so far
according to the definition the vague
definition of the foundation model I
guess marketing department it's not
really research research organization
anymore um so yeah that's just a pet
peeve of mine but fine prompting is
important we get it but prompt
strategies are very manually engineered
so people have asked themselves can this
prompt engineering be automated and
there have already been papers into that
direction the automatic prompt engineer
or AP ape I don't know how you want to
call it is a an attempt into this
direction so they generate an initial
distribution of prompts using another
prompt that infers the problem from from
a number of input output examples from
the data set so you have uh you have
input output examples you take a part of
the data set as a training set let's say
and that those are your demonstrations
of how it's done correctly and from that
you try to infer a prompt that would I
mean it's it's sort of like you like
very classic machine learning you take a
set of examples of how it's correctly
being done and then you train something
that would give you the
correct prompt for that so in that sense
The Prompt here is like the weights of a
regression in the classic sense and the
the examples will be like the data uh
yeah it's a weird world but that people
have tackled automated prompt
engineering uh like this however those
things have given sort of this these
diminishing returns so as they go on and
on trying to improve and improve and
improve the prompt at some point you
sort of hit ceiling really relatively
quickly and that's it they the authors
here say we propose a solution sorry
about that we propose a solution to the
problem of diminishing returns via
diversity maintaining evolutionary
algorithm for self-referential
self-improvement prompts of llms so they
say the reason why the previous
automated prompt engineering efforts
haven't worked out well is that they
didn't maintain diversity as they
improved their their prompts uh they
just sort of improved improved and then
at some point with the initial initial
boost uh to The Prompt if you go into
that direction there is kind of a a
limit but maintaining
diversity is a very well-known technique
in a lot of these sort of exploratory
blackbox optimizers and that's what they
do right here uh if you like if you want
to know more or learn more about these
things um there's a lot of work on
open-ended learning and um I
guess goal-free learning and things like
this um Works originally by
Kenneth Stanley and people around him uh
there i' I've made videos about this
stuff before and it's highly interesting
so there's a lot wealth of things to be
to be explored in this direction and
this paper here goes a little bit into
that in Ed it says hey we want to
maintain diversity of solutions because
what happens is when one gets into a a
point where you can't improve it any
longer you may be able to take some
ideas or approaches from another place
because you've maintained that diversity
Port that over or combine two solutions
and therefore um therefore improve even
more rather than getting stuck in in
some um forget how it's called like a
street where you can't move on I I don't
know the the English word right now
blacking out so the results are the
first thing they show right here you can
see that in various uh data sets there
which is PB here um in zero shot and in
F shot learning or in F shot inference
they Trump the other methods or largely
largely surpass the other
methods yeah now to be said in some of
these things for example the star here
it's not the original number if you want
to compare that to other papers but they
have sort of subdivided it into training
and test samples yes yes we we are back
in the world of training set and test
set um llms if you just use them in zero
shot fashion they can actually solve
tasks sometimes that's what the original
paper large language models are strong
multitask zero shot something like this
Learners was gpt2 paper maybe or gpt3 I
don't know but we're back in the world
of actually using training data so the
way that these prompt Improvement
systems work is by consuming training
data training data of know successful
executions of the task so how does
prompt breeder work this is the overview
that they give right here it all starts
with a initial set initial population
that's up here so initialize
initialization of the population of task
prompts and mutation prompts so they
have two kinds of prompts actually they
have three kinds of prompts actually
they have three kinds of prompts and
then some constant prompts um there are
these thinking Styles right here they
are it it's a bit weird to me why
they're here like in principle I can
totally see that at some point this just
probably didn't work as well as it
should and then they just introduced
say how about we just kind of introduce
different thinking styles to even up the
diversity even more but the thinking
Styles that's just a list of like
thinking Styles one is like let's think
step by step another one is they have a
list down um they have the list down
these are fixed they are just a list of
different thought heuristics not
specific to any problem whatsoever just
like try to think outside of the box or
something like this try to reformulate
or you know try to break the problem
down into different sub pieces or so
thinking
Styles um yeah completely irrelevant to
here except introduced probably to make
it work
better uh the problem
description is very specific to the task
you want to solve for example solve this
solve this math problem give the answer
as a number or something like this is
this a problem description and then
obviously the so-called um mutation
prompts the mutation prompts are can I
take one
prompt sorry that's an R I wanted to
make a p can I take a prompt can I make
it into another prompt via a mutation
prompt so the way that works is you take
a large language model and you feed in
the mutation prompt plus the prompt and
the output is going to be the next
prompt so the mutation prompt is going
to be something like like this
um change this instruction to make it
more fun that's a mutation prompt
because you can concatenate it with a
prompt and they have they have this
structure right here so they put the
word instruction here and then the
problem description and then instruction
mutant right so you kind of C
the language model into giving you a
variant of this prompt right here now at
the very beginning they just mutate the
original description of the task like
solve this math word problem but as the
algorithm goes on um this thing right
here this original task description has
also changed so these things here are P
the prompts and then these things here
these are M the mutation prompts both
both things are going to change so the
prompts are going to improve and the
mutation prompts are also going to
improve over time at least that's the
idea so those are the sets of things
that take part there are prompts there
are mutation prompts there are is the
pro the original problem description
there's a list of thinking Styles there
is a little bit of structure into for
example here instruction instruction
mutant like The Meta prompting so to say
and
that's it except for the mutation
operators down here but we'll get to
that in a bit so the initial population
we just generate like this we take the
original problem description and we use
a initial set of mutation prompts and we
just generate a bunch of variants right
now one thing that wasn't very clear to
me when I read the paper initially was
the following they have what they call
units of mutation and a unit of of or a
unit of evolution a unit of evolution is
a mutation prompt and as far as I
understand and two P
P1 P2 two prompts so the mutation prompt
could be something like we just saw like
reformulate this instruction to make it
I don't know better to make it more fun
to make it more concise something like
this then P1 and P2 are actual prompts
like solve this math problem and however
those
two are used in the following at least
for most tasks that's how I figure it's
not super duper clear but when you
actually get the task like at evaluation
time what you do is you write
P1 then you write the problem
problem like the actual you know here is
the math question um
then you let the llm produce something
so you let it produce something here so
this could already be the solution but
then you put prompt two and then you let
it produce something else and this down
here is what you check for correct
so you have you have for example the
chance of instructing to solve the
problem and then this here bring it into
the correct format like that's a very
common approach uh so first you just
instruct it in some way to solve the
problem and usually these LM they they
they'll put out something like here is
the solution and then they give you the
solution and what you wanted was just
the solution so people have started to
put into the initial prompt like only
provide the solution blah blah BL blah
but it works also equally well if this
really just focuses on solving the
problem and then this focuses on getting
into the correct format of the solution
but there are other things thinkable but
essentially these two prompts together
you can think of sort of like the prompt
except that you structure it in this way
that you first put the first prompt with
the problem you let the model produce
something then you put the second prompt
you let it produce something again and
that's what you check for the
answer another thing apparently the AP
paper introduced this format another
thing that makes it even harder to
compare to just like zero shot prompting
where you just say please solve this
problem right the the the chance that
you have two prompts here and you kind
of inter leave them in any case that's
how they do it now why do they call this
thing here a unit of
evolution they they always evolve the
together so one mutation prompt goes
with one actual task prompt together and
that's not really necessary you could
just maintain a population of mutation
prompts and a population of task prompts
kind of but they do it because they
always need to evaluate Fitness of these
things if you know about evolutionary
algorithm you maintain a population of
these and you want to know what's the
fitness of these like how good are they
how good are these prompts here and how
good is this mutation prompt now the
prompts you can e easily evaluate you
just take a bunch of data points right a
bunch of questions from your training
data set as we said and you evaluate it
and you check whether they get the
correct answer if they get the correct
answer often for a lot of these data
points they're good prompts the mutation
prompt however is a bit more tricky so
the way you evaluate that is
because you have these things
together you save them in a way that um
I believe you always save the mutation
prompt together with the prompts that It
produced the way you would and then it's
really easy to say well if the prompts
are
good that means at least in part the
mutation prompt was good because it
produced these prompts and therefore it
probably didn't do something stupid
right you could also look if if the new
prompts that it mutated are better than
the old prompts that it got as an input
but in essence you keep those together
because you need to evaluate the
mutation prompts and you evaluate the
mutation prompts by by proxy essentially
by evaluating the prompts they produce
so you always keep them together which
is not necessary engineering wise but
that's what they do that's why you see
down here if you look at these things
this is your population right here and
this is an individual in the population
and you can see it's made up of a prompt
and a mutation prompt or alternatively
two prompts and a mutation
prompt and they have a fitness over here
so what do we do now as the algorithm
progresses we're building up this
population as we said and we have
fitnesses and usually what you do is you
order these things by Fitness and then
you just drop away the ones that have a
very low Fitness so that thing right
here you know out you go and is replaced
by another
individual the other individuals you get
by taking the good ones in your
population and mutating them so you
always you want to take the good ones
mutate them and put them back and then
order all by Fitness evaluate everything
and then call away the ones that have a
very low Fitness that's how
evolution-based populationbased
algorithms
work how do they mutate these things and
that's where these mutation operators
come in so they have various ways of
mutating the prompts themselves and that
sometimes makes use of that mutation
prompt right or evolving the mutation
prompt as such so this this is where it
gets a complex these mutation operators
either they take a
prompt and they make a new prompt right
so then if you think of what happens to
the unit of evolution this unit of
evolution is going to be
MP let's just focus on a single prompt
right now not two prompts MP that's
going to be m p Prime as far as I
understand right it's also possible to
for them to take absolutely nothing and
make up a new prompt or just the initial
task description so in that case also
you just replace one of the prompts with
the new prompt with the same mutation
prompt then it's also possible to take a
prompt and a mutation prompt and produce
a new prompt right that's the why we
have the mutation prompts in the first
place so in that case again the mut
mutation prompt pair would be
transferred into the same
mutation P Prime pair so and then it's
also possible to take a mutation
prompt and make a new mutation prompt
and then that you can use to process the
prompt into a new prompt so they have
all these different things that they do
to this population in order to change
the population around and they list them
down
here so okay yada yada yada and then
yeah so they have say they have nine
operators for
mutation the rationale for using this
diverse set of operators is to enable
the llm to explore a large space of
cognitive methods of linguistic
self-questioning by repeatedly changing
the framing of the problem as well as
retrieving mental models expressed in
natural language that can help tackle a
given reasoning
challenge so we'll go through the
mutation operators um and yeah keep in
mind these are things that they do to
change the population around in between
these rounds so every round they want to
change the population they want to
mutate a bunch of the ones they have add
them back into the population then order
them all by Fitness call away the Boton
ones and repeat again and while doing
that so the mutation always concerns the
prompts but also the mutation prompts
that are used sometimes to mutate the
prompts
so direct mutation concerns with just
directly generating a new prompt like a
new P prompt a new task
prompt there they that's what they call
zero of order
Generation Um we generate a new task by
concatenating the problem
description with the prompt a list of
100 hints so this is like the very start
when we just generated our initial list
of prompts uh we just do that again so
in that sense we can always we always
have like a a starting a thing that
generates prompts from the very starting
problem description so we don't kind of
evolve into a place where we get lost
and we have nothing to do anymore with
the original problem which could be a
degener generate State um so they say
it's regenerated from the problem
description each
time this does not use any existing
prompt this does not use a mutation
prompt or anything like this this just
generates new prompts and adds them to
the population then we have first order
prompt
generation here is here what they say we
concatenate the mutation prompt to the
parent task prompt and pass it to the
llm to produce the mutated task promp
prompt for example say that instruction
again in another way don't use any of
the words in the original instruction
there's a good there's a good
Chap and the instruction is solve the
math word problem giving your answer as
an Arabic numeral so this is probably
what you imagine when I tell you there
are mutation prompts and there are
prompts and we use the mutation prompts
in order to mutate the prompts this is
exactly it so we give the mutation
prompt we give the prompt and mutation
prompt says something like change this
prompt to be better and outcomes a new
prompt the procedure they say is is
identical to the initialization method
except that a randomly sampled thinking
style string is not used so
uh in the initialization you use like
the thinking style and here you don't
now so the the whole point of this paper
is kind of can we do something hands off
that is not hand engineered so we don't
have to think about this you know this
prompting thing and really it really
depends on how you do it so we'd rather
not do that ourselves yet so many things
in this paper are clearly done out of
fiddling around because someone
discovered oh if I do it like this it
works better like ooh if I add the
thinking Styles at the beginning then it
works a lot better
so that's a a bit my problem I'd rather
have had a paper that doesn't do a lot
of the things that they do in this paper
to make it
better but instead have sort of a more
solid work of research like a work of
research that actually focuses on what
if we just hands off do the most general
you know straightforward thing and see
how far that gets that would have been
so much more valuable than you know
let's let's add in thinking like
thinking Styles and let's add in this
and the fact that they have these nine
random mutation operators that they have
like here and the exact way they
construct them is also pretty sure a
result of kind of tinkering around and
finguring around so in my estimation
this it just delays the problem to a
different domain namely to The Domain
sort of of meta prompting and so on and
yes probably it's like teaching a person
how to fish instead of giving them a
fish right but to me it's a little bit
too much focused on teaching a person
how to fish that exact one fish in that
exact one pond with the exact one uh
fishing line I give them and if they do
it in exactly my way and also I'm going
to kill the fish first and kind of put
them put it there so they they can just
grab it um yeah plus the fact that
obviously all of this uses training data
which is sort of against the sense of
working with llms but never
mind so then they have um they say look
we can not just condition on zero or one
parent but we can condition on a set of
parents so we provide a filtered and
numbered list of the current population
of task prompts to the llm and ask it to
continue this list with new task prompts
so they're just going to take go through
all their units of so they're all their
units of mutation let's maybe back to
the graphic they're going to go through
all of these right here they're always
going to grab just the prompts out of
each order by their Fitness so they have
an ordered list by their Fitness and
provide that and then they say you know
we could just let the thing continue
that list
right
um but they filter it so they don't want
things that are too similar so if
they're too similar coine similarities
they throw them away so this is kind of
a diverse list uh encouraging
diversity and no sorry my bad this
particular mutation
operator does not provide an ordered
list but just an unordered list that is
focused on diversity by filtering out
very similar
things this next one here provides an
ordered list of the same thing so this
is a variant of the above in which task
prompts are listed in Fitness
order so they say preliminary
experiments show that the LM is more
likely to generate entries that are
similar to The Elements appearing later
in the list they say we ordered the task
prompts in the population by ascending
order of Fitness so the most fit things
are at the end if I understand the
correctly where the uh yeah the llm is
more likely to generate entries that are
similar to the end of the list so the
highest Fitness are at the end of the
list and then they tell the
llm that this is a list of responses in
descending order of
Fitness okay so
uh
yeah so they lie to they lie to the
language
model they say they order it in
ascending order of Fitness so that the
last one which they know the llm focuses
by default on is the best one but then
they say no no no it's actually the
other way around so in the prompt they
say this is a descending order of
fitness and they even clarify it they
say this you know that index is the best
response it
resembles that more than it does that
other one so they really hard try to
convince the language model that it's
the other way around why they say this
is because otherwise it is too biased
towards producing a new entry that is
too similar to the final
entry the contradiction between the
asending ordering and the statement that
it is a descending ordering appears to
improve the diversity of sound sampling
really like this to me here is the most
staggering example
of I have nothing against this I'm all
for you know weird tricks that you know
the initial ones were were like the
Unreal Engine tricks for the diffusion
models I'm all for that but not in a
paper whose explicit reason for existing
is saying well these other things they
just do handcrafted random things that
just they that they just find to work
and and that's not a state of being that
we should solve that problem so here is
like an automated system hands off so
you don't have to handcraft weird things
anymore that just kind of you see
working yeah not in a paper like this um
I get it it improves the score but it in
my opinion diminishes the value of this
particular paper the finding here
to me is great and could be its own
other paper of just saying I found this
weird trick and that's very cool in any
case as we go on here you'll if you know
if you see it in this light you'll see a
lot of the same things um so here they
say lineage based mutation we provide a
history of the individuals in its
lineage of a mutation uh sorry of a unit
of evolution sort of like okay here is
how this this particular unit evolved
over time the ancestors of it like it
was mutated and mutated and mutated and
always remained in the population which
means its Fitness probably increased
over time so they ask well could we just
coax the language model into continuing
that list and
therefore make it even better so they
say look this is a genotypes found in
ascending order of
quality
and you may notice noce now they don't
lie now they don't lie to the language
model they just say this is as sending
order of quality and they actually
provided in a chronological order which
we know given the evolutionary algorithm
is probably an ascending order of
quality because the lineage always
survived in the
past and why would you need why would
you do the trick here and not the same
trick here probably because they found
in the first case it actually improves
things on their particular problem with
their particular method and in the
second case it probably didn't improve
things on their particular thing with
their particular method of doing it yeah
again same
thing and then there's hyper mutation so
that's how do we mutate the mutation
prompts uh there is zeroeth order like
zeroth order prompt mutation is just we
concatenate the original problem
description with a to a randomly sampled
thinking style and feed it to the llm to
generate a new mutation prompt so just
using the thinking Styles as sort of
meta mutation prompts generate a
mutation
prompt again why the thinking Styles
enter here who knows it just worked
better right which thinking styles are
in the list just a bunch first order
hyper mutation we con catenate the hyper
mutation prompt please summarize and
improve the following instruction to a
mutation prompt so that the LM generates
a new mutation prompt again this thing
right here I know it's quite generic but
it is a handcrafted
prompt and then you have Larkin
Evolution where you put a bunch of
examples of how it worked out previously
and try to get the prompt out of this
and you have prompt crossover and
context text shuffling and so on
techniques that are used in evolutionary
algorithms in
general so their results
are okay they're so they're they're
better than the other automated prompt
generation methods and they're also
better than for example hand design
prompts so they say this in this
classification problem this hate speech
classification problem um prompt breeder
was able to involve a prompt strategy
consisting of two sequentially applied
relatively long prompts that scored
89% uh an improvement over the hand
design prompt determine whether text
contains hate speech which scores only
80% if I show you I'm going to show you
these prompts but just look at what it
says this is the hand design prompt is
determine whether a text contain ains
hate speech right I don't know how much
time went into this but it's sort of
can't be more than 30 seconds and I
already get 80% zero shot I have never
looked at any training data I could come
up with this right now right I already
get 80% in order to get to
89% um this entire apparatus is being
used including training dat right
including actually taking data from the
data set and using it as training data
which is very expensive to collect often
plus we are now don't have one prompt we
have two sequentially applied relatively
long prompts that were evolv an
evolutionary algorithm that uses llms on
top of llms to evolve and you get 9
percentage points out of it now granted
that's like 50% % less mistakes if you
think of it like this but still we can
actually go look at this at this stuff
uh so there there's only the appendix
remaining where I want to show you a
bunch of things so here are here are
curves these are very typical of
evolutionary algorithm you start with
generation zero you evolve over time and
you see sort of the the parto Frontier
uh improving and the average fitness
improving which is pretty cool the
mutation prompts um here's a list of of
mutator prompts that are I'm going to
guess the initial ones because or the
evolved
ones this should be described should be
described somewhere I'm not sure I just
found this one funny break free from
conventional
constraints that takes the prompt to
Uncharted
territories it's what what is the world
come to um thinking Styles here's the
list of thinking Styles so something
like are there any stakeholders or
individuals who are directly affected by
the problem what are their perspectives
and needs I mean sure but also this is
competely
engineered um but it is more General
than like I think like I totally believe
that I can throw this thing at various
different problems and it will kind of
do good job at them as long as they're
sort of in the same meta domain as the
problems that we see here in this paper
so take my criticism with a grain of
salt it is a cool work and is definitely
a cool attempt um I I don't want to
denigrate the paper as
such and now
yeah look at some of these results and
that's my last going to be my last CR oh
here is the Evolve prompt for this hate
speech detection look at that look at
that you you think like okay yes yes
that that's probably going to be better
than just saying does the text contain
hate speech but if you read it it's like
I wonder what a human could do by just
spending 15 minutes right um
yeah evolved mutation prompts
the top one is please summarize and
improve the following
instruction this is the most successful
mutation prompts evolved in a
self-referential
way you can see that the top the top
scoring mutation prompt is
essentially what you would come up
initially um I mean it's cool but it's
does it really necessitate this entire
Machinery also here the mutation
operators that are the most
effective are zeroth order hyper
mutation so where you just kind of come
up with a new mutation prompt um lineage
based mutation is interesting that it's
so high and first order hyper mutation
also shows that okay reformulating the
prompts in some way is important what's
also important is that there is no super
duper dominant uh mutation operator here
that means all the mutation operators
kind of contribute that's a positive
result I would guess for this paper even
though the sort of zero if order things
being at the top is probably the it it's
probably more than was or different than
was hoped for because what you hope for
is sort of that that the most int
intricate ones go to the top and that
those are the really important ones
where you take a mutation prompt that
was evolved already and evolve it more
and then use that to change a regular
prompt and and that mutation is really
but I guess I guess that's kind of this
if you think about it except that you
don't I guess this one here would
be
yeah that one here would sort of be the
core of the paper the first order hyper
mutation where you mutate a mutation
prompt you use that to mutate a task
prompt and then that is really important
so I guess it's a good result that
that's in in third place so here are
some
examples uh after
1,600
mutations and this is a two prompt thing
okay that's what's
evolved zero is the m mutant and prompt
one is
mutant that's it so the tasks are like
the tasks are I don't even know what the
tasks are ad sub but it's like a bit of
math
problems um they say themselves we find
that in the fucha evolution case the
contexts Dominate and often the tasks
prompts drift into nonsense they're less
critically determining of Fitness than
the evolved
context oh evolve context I've didn't
touch on this but they also essentially
evolve which few shot examples get into
the context and determining those well I
guess can make a difference of that
being said every time they use training
data they completely use in domain
training data like the same distribution
as the test
data uh yeah there are
more so there is math problems solve the
math word problem giving your answer as
an Arabic
numeral have you solved the problem like
this
before like this is interesting it's
interesting that this is what works well
but also I I have my doubts that that
that is really the best prompt it's sort
of a self assessment thing but if you
look through these examples you could
definitely definitely so these are also
math problems um I would solve the math
word problem without using a calculator
giving my answer as an Arabic numeral
okay that's a fine prompt I guess but
then the next prompt is 1 2 3
yeah and here you it's you just shout
you just Shout at the language model you
hope that improves
it I okay here is where I actually
believe that that this is this is a good
prompt just shout and that's it uh here
the first prompt is just kind of a date
range um and this has nothing to do with
dates these are also math problems as
you can see right here
so
doubt press X to
doubt like it's definitely cool work but
if you look at the actual results
um
it's sometimes questionable
whether
the
[Music]
whether whether it really does something
sensible right uh or whether the results
we see like the good numbers are
more like there's something else that
contributes to them that's just kind of
the nature of these problems or some
kind of circumvention of this and
whether this is really the method that
involves these evolves these Stellar
prompts especially as they could
generalize to other things and do more
stuff and we could extend this method I
remain doubtful nevertheless this is it
is an actual cool work um and I'm very
happy that people are researching into
this and I'm very excited where it goes
from here don't get me wrong so thank
you a lot to people from Google Deep
Mind for researching this and I hope we
can continue and I hope uh the yeah I
hope the next steps in this uh are
better and better and better and at some
point we won't have to write prompts or
meta prompts or hyper prompts or
anything anymore like this excellent
thanks for listening bye-bye